let me say something very controversial
right now if you're going through
puberty as a boy you're going to have a
male puberty experience and if you're
going through puberty as a girl you're
going to have a girl female puberty
experience you may go Dave what kind of
Segway is that what could you possibly
be doing next well here's dick Levine
our favorite Admiral dick Levine who has
interviewed a day or two ago being asked
just to show you how crazy these people
are everything they say is not just a
lie a lie would be one thing we could
put a lie in a pocket that we could get
rid of it everything they do is a
massive 180 smack you in the face with a
pie lie that's what they do
here's
This Woman This Man oh God I almost did
it you see what you see what happened
here this guy this guy
is just watch the video just watch the
video what would you say to folks who
think that they're being reasonable by
saying why can't children just wait till
they're 18. the adolescence is hard and
puberty is hard what if you're going
through the wrong puberty what if you
inside feel that you are female but now
you're going through a male puberty not
he should be fired immediately you
cannot go through the wrong puberty your
body is your body when you are of a
certain age if you wish to dress
whichever way you want and put lipstick
on and all that that's just fine
you cannot go through the wrong puberty
the fact that this person has anything
to do with the health of anyone and that
this guy we've shown you the video has
repeatedly said that he is thrilled that
he did not transition when he was young
because his two children that he has
that he was the father to now I suppose
purports to be the mother that he those
are the biggest joys in his life and
that's what he's trying to steal from 13
year old kids
well we have an editing machine over
here in the studio and we put together a
little something we're going to show you
the same clip with a little twist I
think you're going to enjoy
what would you say to folks who think
that they're being reasonable by saying
why can't children just wait till
they're 18. the adolescence is hard and
puberty is hard what if you're going
through the wrong puberty what if you
inside feel that you are female but now
you're going through a male puberty what
you've just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things I have ever heard
at no point in your rambling incoherent
response were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational
thought
everyone in this room is now Dumber for
having listened to it
I award you no points
and may God have mercy on your soul
that's Billy Madison Peak Adam Sandler I
think around 1995 if I'm not mistaken if
I had a nickel for every time that I got
stoned in college and watched that movie
I'd have a small fortune but these
people lie about everything
[Music]
thank you